Yeah, seamless, seamless transition.
I get to follow that.
That's fantastic.
Well, thank you so much for having me.
It really is a pleasure and an honor to be here with you all this morning to open up
God's Word together.
So thankful for this church family.
I come from Redeemer Community Church just down the road, down the hill, about 10,
15 minutes.
We started as a church plant about 18 years ago this month.
And we gathered in a home.
And it has been such a joy to see over the years we've been able to participate in planting
two churches, and this, your congregation being one of those.
And so it is a joy and a privilege to be here with you today.
And to continue your study of the book of Exodus, I got to listen back to some of the
sermons throughout the series.
And so it's really fun.
I've had so much fun this past week in Exodus 15 studying God's Word so we could share
together in this time.
And so with that, I'd like to begin by reading verses one through 18.
It's printed there in your worship guide.
If you have a Bible with you, I'd encourage you to get it out.
We will also be looking at Exodus 6 at one point and then a couple of verses throughout.
And so if you've got a Bible, you can open up to Exodus 15.
It's there in your worship guide as well.
I'm going to read verses one through 18 and let us listen carefully for this is God's
Word.
I will sing to the Lord for He has triumphed gloriously.
The horse and the rider He has thrown into the sea.
The Lord is my strength in my song.
He has become my salvation.
This is my God and I will praise Him.
My Father's God and I will exalt Him.
The Lord is a man of war.
The Lord is His name.
Pharaoh's chariots and his host, he cast into the sea and his chosen officers were
sunk in the Red Sea.
The floods covered them.
They went down in the depths like a stone.
Your right hand, O Lord, glorious in power.
Your right hand, O Lord, shatters the enemy.
In the greatness of Your Majesty, You overthrow Your adversaries.
You send out Your fury.
It consumes them like stubble.
At the blast of Your nostrils, the waters piled up and floods stood up in a heap.
The depths, the deeps congealed in the heart of the sea.
The enemy said, I will pursue You.
I will overtake.
I will divide the spoil.
My desire shall have its fill of them.
I will draw my sword.
My hand shall destroy them.
You blew with Your wind.
The sea covered them.
They sink like lead in the mighty waters.
Who is like You, O Lord, among the gods?
Who is like You, majestic in holiness, awesome in glorious deeds, doing wonders?
You stretched out Your right hand and the earth swallowed them.
You have led in Your steadfast love the people whom You have redeemed.
You have guided them by Your strength to Your holy abode.
The peoples have heard, they trembled.
Pangs have seized the inhabitants of Philistia.
Now are the chiefs of Edom dismayed.
Trimbling seizes the leaders of Moab.
All the inhabitants of Canaan have melted away.
Terror and dread fall upon them.
Because of the greatness of Your arm, they are still as a stone.
Till Your people, O Lord, pass by.
Till the people by whom You have purchased.
You will bring them in and plant them on Your own mountain.
The place, O Lord, which You have made for Your abode.
The sanctuary, O Lord, which Your hands have established.
The Lord will reign forever and ever.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray together.
O Lord our God, as we open Your word together, as we are reminded that You alone are ruler
over heaven and earth.
You alone are mighty to save and majestic in holiness.
We acknowledge Your, our desperate need for Your truth in our lives.
Not only that we would walk in Your ways, but that we would know You and treasure You above
all else.
So as we meditate on Your word this morning, would You meet us by Your Spirit and lead
us to life everlasting in Christ Jesus, our Lord?
So would You speak, Lord, for Your servants are listening?
You pray this in the name of the Father, the Son, and the Holy Spirit.
Amen.
The words of Exodus 15 are a song of fulfillment.
It begins by saying that then Moses and the people of Israel sang this song to the
Lord.
It's a song of fulfillment.
They declare what God has promised to them has come true.
For us to understand what this song of fulfillment is about, we have to first remember what the
words of promise were to begin with.
And from the beginning of the story of the Exodus, God made a promise.
And it was Moses' task to take this promise and to make it known to the people in captivity
and slavery in Egypt.
The promise was multifaceted.
There are lots of parts to the promise.
But one thing especially stands out.
And that's that God was going to have to do all the work.
For the promise to come true, it would take God alone to make it all happen.
And so if you have your Bible, let's look quickly at Exodus 6, where this promise is
stated.
Exodus 6, beginning in verse 6, it says this, Say therefore to the people of Israel.
This is God stating the promises through Moses and saying, Moses, say this to the people.
I am the Lord and I will bring you out from under the burdens of the Egyptians, and I
will deliver you from slavery to them.
And I will redeem you with an outstretched arm and with great acts of judgment.
I will take you to be my people.
I will be your God.
And you shall know that I am the Lord, your God who brought you out from under the
burdens of the Egyptians.
That's the big promise.
There are kind of three sections to this promise.
This promise that God gave to Moses to convey to the people.
The first section is the promise of I am.
I am the Lord.
Remember, this is the personal name of God that he revealed to Moses.
God begins with the promise of who he is.
Then it moves to a second section of promise.
It's the I will.
So the first one is the I am.
It now moves to I will.
These are multiple promises of action that the Lord will carry out on behalf of the people.
He says that I will bring you out.
I will deliver you.
I will redeem you.
I will take you.
I will be your God.
And then that third section is the response.
The promised result from those first two of who God is and what he's going to do.
It moves to a response.
It says you will.
You will know that I am the Lord, your God.
We are told that these powerful words of promise, they were shared by Moses to the people
and they were immediately dismissed by them.
They didn't believe it.
And the Scriptures say that the reason that they didn't believe it was because
of their broken spirits.
They were so worn down, so broken by their generations of oppression and despair that they could not
believe that anything or anyone could ever rescue them out of it.
They didn't believe that anything like that could happen for them.
But from that point on, from when this declaration happened, through the plagues, through death,
through the Red Sea itself.
Yahweh was fulfilling this promise that he made through Moses.
This unbelievable and often unbelieved promise of God was advancing no matter what.
And here at the close of chapter 14 and the beginning of 15, the people of God now
stand on dry ground.
They stand on the seashore.
Astonished, amazed, and also afraid because they have beheld with their own eyes the great
power of the Lord.
And in that power, the power of His promises.
And so on that shore, the people do the only thing that a person can do when they have seen
and beheld the greatness and the graciousness of God.
They do the only reasonable response to having seen with their own eyes the power and the glory
of the Lord.
They worship Him.
Exodus 15 verse 1, then Moses and the people of Israel sang this song to the Lord.
You might have noticed this before in your Bible reading, but the original songwriters
for the church were the prophets.
Throughout the Scriptures, both in the Old Testament and the New Testament, we
read of men and women who are prophets of the Lord.
And once they have beheld the Lord's greatness, they break into this divine hymn singing.
The prophet Deborah sings.
Elisha, Asaph, Habakkuk, David, and Hannah, they all sing.
And in the New Testament with the birth of Jesus, it's accompanied by multiple prophetic
hymns, hymns from Zechariah, from Simeon, from Mary.
It makes sense that those whom the Lord has granted the spiritual wisdom, spiritual vision,
as they have beheld the power and the might of God, that it would overflow into glorious
worship.
That's the fitting response to experiencing and knowing who God is and knowing the fulfillment
of his promises.
So let's continue together this morning looking at this prophetic hymn of Exodus 15, this
hymn of Moses and the people who, though for their entire lives, had only known the bitterness
of captivity, but who now, by no might or strength of their own, are standing on the
shores of freedom.
To help us consider this song and its content, we're going to break the song into four
different parts, four lessons found in the lyrics of this song of Moses.
Four specific lessons that the people of God have come to learn in their extraordinary journey
of the Exodus.
And those four lessons unfold in these lyrics of the songs.
So the first lesson, I'm just going to list them out for us and then we'll dig into them.
The first lesson, Yahweh is victorious.
The second lesson, Yahweh is supreme.
The third, Yahweh is the redeemer.
And fourth, Yahweh is forever.
So that first lesson, Yahweh is victorious.
It's declared in verse three and it's demonstrated in verses four through ten.
It begins by saying, the Lord is a man of war.
The Lord is his name.
Now if you see the Lord in all caps, that means the personal name of God, it said Yahweh
there.
And so it says Yahweh is a man of war.
Your translation might say the great warrior.
The Lord is the warrior.
Yahweh is his name.
The people have seen the victory of the Lord over their enemies.
They had never dared to dream that their enemy truly could be defeated.
They had understood since they were children, they were generations, hundreds of years in
slavery.
And they did not even dare to dream that someone among them could rise up and take on Pharaoh
and his army.
They were people enslaved, dominated and oppressed.
They'd been there for hundreds of years, generation after generation, born into slavery and dying.
Longing for freedom, but knowing that their oppressor was too mighty, too powerful
to overcome.
And yet, now they stand with their feet not only on dry land, but they stand in freedom
and liberation.
And in response to what they have just experienced, they begin to sing and they declare what they
have watched the Lord do as a warrior who brings victory.
Pharaoh's chariots and his hosts, he cast into the sea, verse 4 says.
And his chosen officers were sunk in the Red Sea.
A theme that we see throughout the Old Testament, a common belief in the ancient Near East was
that the waters were a picture of chaos, a picture of death.
No one can control the seas.
And yet here Yahweh uses the waters as an expression of his authority over all creation
and his authority as he puts Pharaoh and his armies to flight and judgment.
Notice that the people do not take any credit for their victory.
Every line of the hymn declares God's power to overthrow the oppressors of his people.
They do not say that Yahweh made them into men of war.
They don't say that Yahweh strengthened them for battle or gave them skill or speed
or strategy.
Yahweh alone is the warrior and their exodus is completely due to his power and his majesty.
That is what they are singing.
This displays for us that real worship, genuine worship of God puts all attention and affection
on him alone.
There's no room for self-promotion, self-celebration, self-centeredness.
The spotlight is for God alone, Father, Son and Spirit.
He alone receives all glory, honor and praise.
The people are right to do this because they know beyond question that they are standing
in this place of freedom and liberty because of what God has done.
Yes, the people were obedient.
Much of what you all have looked at in the last couple of chapters is their obedience
to the Lord.
They put the blood on the doorpost.
They stood ready to flee the city holding their staffs in hand and they had to trust
God to lead them through those parted waters.
But they did not mistake their obedience as the cause of the victory.
God commanded and utilized their obedience, but the victory was the Lord's alone.
The people burst into song declaring this truth.
That's the first lesson.
Yahweh is victorious.
The second lesson of promise.
Yahweh is supreme.
It's declared in verse 11, demonstrated in verse 12.
Let's look together.
Verse 11, who is like you a Lord among the gods, who is like you majestic and holiness,
awesome and glorious deeds doing wonders.
You stretched out your right hand and the earth swallowed them.
The incomparable nature of God is declared here.
The people have seen the Lord's victory.
They have seen his glorious power, the greatness of his majesty on display.
And they responded by declaring there is no one like him.
And they have beheld his majestic holiness.
They've been awed by his glorious deeds and wonders.
And they saw his unmatched holiness and glory when he stretched out his hand against their
enemies and swallowed them up in an instant.
It's a crucial lesson that will be repeated throughout the scriptures.
The hymn writer, King David would declare in Psalm 86, there is none like you among the
gods, O Lord.
Nor are there any works like yours.
All the nations you have made shall come and worship before you, O Lord, and shall glorify
your name for you are great and do wondrous things.
You alone are God.
The prophet Micah, Micah whose very name in Hebrew means who is like Yahweh.
If your name is Micah, you might have just found that out.
There's a little something for you.
Micah, who is like Yahweh?
In Micah chapter 7 verse 18 it says, who is a God like you, pardoning iniquity and passing
over transgression for the remnant of his inheritance.
He does not retain his anger forever because he delights instead fast love.
No one is like Yahweh.
No one compares to his glory.
His deeds, his power, his mercy.
That's the second lesson.
Yahweh is supreme over everything.
The third lesson.
Yahweh is redeemer.
This is declared in verse 13 and then demonstrated in 14 through 17.
When it says in verse 13, you have led your steadfast love, you have led in your steadfast
love the people whom you have redeemed.
You have guided them by your strength to your holy abode.
In verse 17, you will bring them in and plant them on your own mountain.
The place, O Lord, which you have made for your abode, the sanctuary, O Lord, which is
your hands have established.
God promised the people that he would bring them out of their bondage and slavery.
He promised redemption and he said that he would do all of this action himself.
All those, I will, I will, I will.
He does it by the strength of his own arm and on the seashore of freedom, the people see
God's promise of redemption fulfilled.
He is their redeemer.
He has done it.
He has brought them out of slavery and death and into life with him.
As we read from chapter six, Yahweh revealed to Moses that this was his objective.
He would bring the people out and he would plant them in his own place.
He would establish his dwelling place with them and they would be a people for his own
possession, rescued and redeemed from oppression into life with God.
Verse 16 refers to the people as those whom God has purchased.
Purchased himself.
The people were bought with a price that only Yahweh could afford.
And in purchasing them from slavery, they have been liberated to life with God.
The price was paid because God alone is rich in mercy.
God alone delights in his steadfast love, the great love with which he loved his people.
And he loved them even when they were in captivity, even when they were in rebellion,
even when they were dead in their sins and their trespasses, even when they didn't
believe him.
He loved them and he was set about the work of their redemption.
So that's the third lesson.
Yahweh is the Redeemer and the fourth lesson.
Yahweh is forever.
We see this in verse 18.
This is how the hymn closes.
The Lord will reign forever and ever.
The people can delight in the Lord, not only because of all of the mighty deeds
that He has just accomplished for them, but they can rejoice in Yahweh with confidence
because his throne and his reign over all that is seen and unseen is forever.
Yahweh is eternal, not only in His being, but also in His reigning.
It's one thing for a man of war to achieve victory in battle, or even a victory over a
war, but it's an altogether different thing entirely when the victor reigns forever.
Every superpower has ended eventually.
Every empire has diminished or fallen.
Every king, emperor, ruler, pharaoh, Caesar, Khan, Kaiser has either been overthrown by
might or they have been overthrown by the grave.
They've all ceased to reign, but the people of God are declaring the eternal reign of
Yahweh.
And throughout the history of the people of God, from those seashores till today,
there has been a cry of God's people declaring the eternal reign of Yahweh alone.
No one else is worthy of this praise.
It is God and God alone.
Which brings us back to the beginning of the song, the opening confession that we read
in verse two that says, the Lord is my strength and my song.
And He has become my salvation.
This is my God and I will praise Him.
My Father's God and I will exalt Him.
The people join together and confess, this is my God.
I will praise Him.
The people find both their purpose and their identity in God alone.
He is their God and they are His people and their purpose, their aim, their ambition is
to worship Him.
This is exactly what God promised to Moses that would happen when he declared to him
regarding all that he would do, all that he would accomplish, all of those I will
statements of action.
The result of all of that is that the people would know that he is the Lord their God.
Yahweh was not only victorious in fulfilling His promise to rescue the people, but He
also fulfilled His promise that they would know that he is the Lord.
And in knowing Him, they would find life and freedom and love eternal.
So through this song, this hymn of celebration, acknowledging the promises of God fulfilled
in redemption.
So we've been going through these things this morning, considering the lyrics of this
song together.
Have you heard the melody of the gospel throughout it?
Have you heard the echo of Jesus throughout this song?
Because it's there.
His life, his death, his resurrection, his work of redemption is throughout Exodus
15.
It is woven throughout every line, every lyric of this song.
It's all pointing to Jesus.
This is the ultimate fulfillment of God's promise of ultimate redemption.
Because ultimate redemption is not just liberation from a wicked empire or an oppressive nation.
Ultimate redemption is eternal rescue from sin and death.
The ultimate exodus is not just out of Egypt.
It's out of the grave itself.
That is the promise of God's mercy brought to us through Jesus alone.
Because you, you who are in Christ are the people who were bought with a price that only
Yahweh could afford.
We read in the letter, in the Acts, in the book of Acts when Paul is talking to the
Ephesian elders.
We read it also in the letter to the Hebrews that the people of God were purchased by the
blood of God himself.
It is the price that only Yahweh could afford.
No one else lives in the luxury of that wealth, but God alone.
And he could pay the price of purchasing you from slavery, slavery to sin and to
death.
And you have been liberated from death into life with God.
The price was paid because God alone is rich in mercy.
God alone delights in his steadfast love and the great love with which he loves you.
And he loved you even when you were in captivity, even when you were in rebellion, even when
you were enemies with God.
We read in Romans chapter five.
Even at that moment, his love was set on you.
Even when you were dead in your sins and your trespasses that we read in Ephesians chapter
two, even when you did not believe him yet, he loved you and he was already doing the
work of your redemption because Christ is victorious.
Christ is supreme.
Christ is our Redeemer.
Christ will reign forever.
To highlight this beautiful reality of fulfillment in Christ, let's connect these lessons from
the song of Moses to the glory of Jesus.
Okay?
I'll do this rather quickly.
There's a lot here.
We could spend a lot more time.
I don't know what the least, I don't know how long we have here.
I'm just a guest.
So I could keep talking as long as I wanted, I guess, but then I might not ever see
you again and I would prefer that.
So I'll go quickly.
Christ is victorious.
The Apostle Paul tells us in 1 Corinthians chapter 15, the sting of death is sin.
The power of sin is the law, but thanks be to God who gives us the victory through our
Lord Jesus Christ.
Christ is supreme.
In Colossians chapter one, we read, he is the image of the invisible God, the first
born of all creation, for by him all things were created in heaven and on earth, visible
and invisible, whether thrones or dominions or rulers or authorities, all things were created
through him and for him.
He is supreme.
He is before all things and in him all things hold together.
And he is the head of the body of the church.
He is the beginning, the first born from the dead, that in everything, us included
in everything, he might be preeminent.
Christ is supreme.
Christ is our redeemer.
Galatians chapter three.
Now it is evident that no one is justified before God by the law, for the righteous shall
live by faith.
But the law is not faith, rather the one who does them shall live by them.
Christ redeems us from the curse of the law.
Christ alone is our redeemer, our liberator, our deliverer.
And Christ is forever.
Hebrews chapter one.
But of the Son, Jesus, the Lord says, your throne, oh God, is forever and ever.
The scepter of uprightness is the scepter of your kingdom.
Jesus sits upon a throne that has no end.
Because he is without end, because he reigns forever, we can stand in a confidence on those
seashores of liberty and freedom.
We can stand with confidence because he is not leaving his throne.
Jesus is the ultimate fulfillment of God's promise of deliverance and redemption.
Jesus leads us through his own sacrifice, through his own atonement out of the bondage of
our sin and death.
And he gives us an exodus of victory, redemption from the grave.
And we learn from John, the apostle John, in his revelation that the song of Moses will
be sung again.
It will be sung again by the people of God.
And it is enjoined with a new song, the song of the Lamb.
And so we read in Revelation chapter 15.
And I do like any time the Bible makes it easy on me when I can remember.
Exodus 15 is the song of Moses and comes back again in Revelation 15 where we read.
And I saw what appeared to be a sea of glass mingled with fire.
And also those who had conquered the beast and its image and the number of its name,
standing beside the sea of glass with harps of God in their hands.
And they sing the song of Moses, the servant of God, the song of the Lamb saying, Great
and amazing are your deeds, O Lord God Almighty.
Just and true are your ways, O King of the nations, who will not fear, O Lord, and glorify
your name.
For you alone are holy.
All nations will come and worship you, for your righteous acts have been revealed.
May our souls learn the lyrics of these promises.
May our souls learn the melody of Christ and His gospel so that we might join with
all the saints of the people of God declaring His greatness and His graciousness both now
and forever.
Let's go to Him now in prayer.
O Lord our God, by your spirit would you write the truth of your greatness and your graciousness
upon our hearts.
And that we who have been ransomed and redeemed by the very blood of God would turn to you
with lives of worship, lives that declare the truths of these songs, lives that seek
to honor you, glorify you in all that we do.
Would help us by your spirit today to love you more, to trust you more, and to obey
you from our hearts that you might be glorified in all that we do.
Be with us now as we reflect on your word and help us by your spirit to turn to Jesus
all the more.
May we see Him as beautiful, our victorious Redeemer.
In the name of the Father, the Son, and the Spirit.
Amen.